martinez currently the highest era among
major league pitchers with at least 65
innings 6-6-2
leads the club in losses with eight
second most in the national league with
luis castillo
he has reached base safely in each of
his last 27 games going back to
september 19th of last year
which is the longest active streak in
all of major league baseball and
in the left ground ball had the right
direction
as it got past paul deyoung at his first
and second
and brian reynolds he's been swinging a
hot bat really for a month now
after key brian hayes singles so too
does brian reynolds and brian reynolds
gives the pirates a one-nothing lead
a nine-game hitting streak for him and
the ball's up and it's 79.
that's just at the big league level it's
gonna get hit colin moran
and a chopper to the right side that
will bring home a run and it was so
slowly hit
even the slow-footed moran beats it out
as hayes
scores the pirates lead two-nothing chad
cool
holding opponents to a 238 average
real good start his last time out
against the indians now the right-handed
ready and the 2-2 pitch
swing of the miss struck about 95 at the
top of the zone there he is one out
and gets a a chase
good work two outs strikeout ground out
brings up nolan aronado here's the pitch
swing and a miss struck him out on what
looked like a backup slider
up and in to the top of the order and
adam frazier just creating more
traffic and more trouble here's a swing
and a ground ball to first fare ball
stepping on the bag goldsmith throw to
second double play
3-6 on the double play here is lars newt
barr
nudebar has his first major league hit
that was a triple yesterday
runner at second two outs the pitch a
swing and a shot up the middle base at
center field
coming around third tyler o'neal and
there's an rbi for lars newt barr
with his second big league hit his
second big league rbi
two to one pirates it is dangerous
because
he's already walked five in this game
and the bases will be loaded
for kevin newman little flare shallow
center
catch made that's carlson and now he's
in out away from getting
out of the jam he's eight for 19 in his
career with the bases loaded
first pitch and he hits it out to right
newt barr is there martinez and the
cardinals
escape one out single here is goldsmith
[Applause]
roller six four
three well done chad cool eat off double
neck snaps an over 12 for the eighth
place hitter michael perez and the
leadoff man is aboard
it's the bunt down orinato has a play
and the throw is a little tardy but they
get the lead man they run right into and
out
arenado two to young runners at the
corners
brian reynolds with two outs another fly
ball to right
hit deep and clear the deck with a
cannonball an anchor down in saint louis
brian reynolds a three-run homer
pirates take a 5-1 lead in the fourth
you love the long ball you love the
three-run homer even more we were just
talking about
how these are game changers a big swing
of the bat looked like a change up that
he left up
definitely one didn't want to leave it
there the way reynolds is swinging the
bat you're not
going to get away with many mistakes
that was a big-time mistake
struck out his first time up against
cool
comes back with a breaking ball and high
in the air to gamble didn't get all of
it
so gamble toward the corner able to make
the catch for the first out
talk about molina getting the ball on
the ground and hitting into a
like a six four three double play
something like that
beautiful polanco has walked twice
tonight
the second time an intentional walk to
load the bases here's a chopper to first
nice bounce for goldschmidt leading
carlos who gets over to the bag 3-1 on
the out
first base to the pitcher covering
here's a check swing and a swing on the
appeal
and that's strike three on kevin newman
he couldn't hold up in time
on one and two the pitch is grounded to
goldschmidt he steps on the back perez
is out
gamble who walked is left on and already
a cult hero of sorts
lars newt barr here's the pitch to him
and a swing and a ground ball chopped
toward first moran came off the back but
has time to get back
as frazier fields ball on the ground in
a pool side
edmond takes second with one out
lifted toward right and polanco
two outs in the bottom of the fifth two
outs runner at second and a 2-1 pitch to
carpenter pop-up
shallow left hayes out hayes puts it
away
into the left hand of batting frazier
fly ball to right field and out
goes frasier clear the deck with a
cannonball
adam frazier hits his fourth buckos
up 6-1 and again uh adam frazier
make mistakes he might be on one of
those tears now we've been seeing the
base hits haven't seen the power for
much of the first half but
it seems like when he gets one there's
another coming behind it
as philip evans pinch hits phillip at
216 with those four
april home runs and now evans lines one
to left field that's deep toward the
fence
and it just clears it clearing the deck
look out rich rod phillip
evans goes deep a pinch hit home run
for philip evans and the pirates
increase their lead
it is now a 7-1 ball game first career
pinch hit home run
for philip evans it's number five
on the season for him he didn't get all
of it but didn't have to a little bit
off the end of the bat
and just enough distance to get into
that bullpen and
frazier homer to the sixth and now moran
gonna dump one into left center field
gonna bring home another moran singles
home frasier
pirates pouring it on now in saint louis
8-1
with the bases loaded hardly was able to
get the first two
and now the 3-2 pitch oh we almost hit
him and now run will score
and this makes it an 8-2 ball game a
base is loaded walk
one more out to get for bednar in the
box
and raise the jolly roger the pirates
defeat the cardinals 8-2